ce carrefour à Carson porte un nom à
propos la place des armateurs cru et
l'ironie car il est en effet devenu un
centre de navigation toutes sortes
d'embarcations ont été mobilisées pour
évacuer les habitants des zones inondées
ma maison est engloutie on ne voit que
le toit que le toit
S
[Musique]
ceux positionnés de l'autre côté du
fleuve ce qui partent aujourd'hui avec
décidé de rester malgré le risque
j'en ai ma claque j'étais chez moi
maintenant il y a de l'eau jusqu'au
deuxième étage
Rocky au pied parmi les naufragés il y a
beaucoup d'animaux domestiques mais pas
que
je l'ai trouvé dans l'escalier j'allais
pas le laisser se noyer hier soir notre
maison était sèche mais quand on s'est
réveillé ce matin il y avait un maître
d’eau
on a attendu d'être évacué et on nous a
amené ici en bateau
la plupart des rescapés disent qu'ils
contestaient dans les quartiers situés
plus en hauteur car il ne risque pas
d'être inondé
mais toute la ville sera affectée par le
désastre pendant plusieurs années selon
le vice-Premier ministre ukrainien venu
évaluer les dégâts
les régions de rerson nicolaïve ni pro
auront certainement et ont déjà des
problèmes en ce qui concerne l'accès à
l'eau potable il s'agit de centaines de
milliers d'habitants dans notre pays qui
sont déjà contraints par ce problème et
je trouve maintenant avec l'équipe
gouvernementale et des représentants des
administrations militaires nous
travaillons pour atténuer les effets de
cette catastrophe
il faudra une semaine pour que l'autre
tir des années pour que le pays se
remette